hello everyone and welcome to another
game from round 12 of the 2021
candidates tournament uh it's van gaal
versus yaniponishi and this game stirred
uh some controversy
uh on online between uh some of you
uh and we're gonna get to that but it it
doesn't appear that
there is a much merit to this uh but you
know
you'll be the judge of that so uh
without further ado let's check it out
one hall versus yani ponchini
she is the leader of the tournament and
if how wins this then i guess he
he could be uh you know but maybe still
fighting for
for the actual win but it's it's hard to
say uh so here uh he opens with
e4 and i would just like to mention now
for those of you who
maybe still haven't joined we have a
telegram channel
where uh you know we discuss we discuss
things and
when where you can uh receive a
notification for a video earlier if you
know maybe you don't receive a youtube
notifications
so if you guys are interested in that i
will put a link to it in the description
below we had some problems uh if you
were from india you couldn't
join uh like a month ago but we fixed
that uh and now
everyone should be able to join so if
you're still into that uh do
do join us we we have a really good time
there
so after e4 nepo decided to go with e5
we have knight to f3 and
knight to f6 and nipple goes for the
petrov defense we have knight captures
on e5 and now
d6 chasing the knight back knight to f3
and
knight captures on e4 so this is all uh
very standard stuff
and my personal favorite is knight the
c3 uh but
here we have d3 and this is um not uh
well this is not new this is in fact an
old way to play this but i guess it's
you know coming back into fashion so
here knight f6 we have d4
and now d5 black also uh grabs
more space in the center we have bishop
to d3 and
bishop to d6 so very uh
you know uh just a nice nicely
proportional uh
development uh we have queen to e to
check and nipple uh very happily obliges
he
doesn't want to play anything too crazy
he's leading the candidates tournament
so you know he has the black pieces
against the
uh renowned chess player like wang hao
so he's very much
happy slow playing this so queen
captures an e7
king captures now and castles uh we
ignite the c6
uh just developing you could also play i
guess c6 but
this is uh this isn't really uh how this
line is played
so knights the c6 uh and now uh
here we have c3 and c3 is a new move in
this position
there's a known game uh rook to e1 check
was played maxim bashar grav defeated
a young shisht of duda in the skilling
open last year uh or
rather this year let me just check
i can't really remember uh yeah it was
last year of course
in the skilling open nbl defeated duda
uh
and here uh after uh knight to c6 we
have c3 and it is now
as of mov 11 that we have a completely
new game
so here h6 taking away the g5 square
from the knight and the bishop
and knight the h4 now here uh how wants
to play
knight to f5 and force black to give up
the dark square bishop but this is
uh this is exactly what jan is going for
we have rook to e8 preparing to castle
artificially
knight to f5 check and nipple castles
now he gives up the bishop pair
but as you'll see he will close up the
position as much as possible
to make the house bishop appear not
not fully operational so bishop captures
an f5
king to f8 now the artificial castling
is complete
and g3 now uh we have knight the e7
uh attacking the light square bishop and
uh bishop back to h3 we have
knight the c8 as you all know the
strongest move is with the knight back
and now knight to d2 and here are a5
we have a4 preventing b5 and now c6 so
black wants to keep a nice close
position
uh so that white's a bishop pair will
not uh you know come
uh come fully operational so here rook
to d1
it's a bit hard for white to get uh his
pieces into the game he still needs to
get a good square for the knight he
needs to bring the bishop into the game
and only then can he
confront the blacks very strong rook on
e8 so here rook to d1
now you can bring your your king for
example to f1 maybe you can trade rooks
like this
uh we have h5 and now knight to f1
that we have g6 by black and now f3
uh we have knight to b6 and now sorry
knight to b6 and
now b3 preventing the knight from coming
to c4
so the position is very much closed and
this uh is what
knights enjoy we have king to g7 and now
king to f2
knight b back to d7 now with ids of
maybe bringing the rook over to
the c8 maybe pushing c5 and bishop to g5
now now the bishop is developed that the
rooks have been connected
and knight to f8 bringing the knights to
e6 to put pressure on this bishop on g5
so rook the e1 finally how can bring his
rooks to the open e file and the knights
the e6 now
and like we said the position is very
much closed and maybe
just maybe white should capture here
uh because the the bishops aren't doing
all that
of an impressive job in in a closed
structure such as this one
but how decides to keep it uh for later
maybe the position opens up maybe the
bishop pair will
come fully operational so rook 8 c8 now
preparing to strike in the center with
c5 and
bishop to d2 if the c file opens up
you will have the c3paw nicely defended
but also if for example captures
captures you will be also attacking the
a5 pawn so bishop to d2 makes sense
uh c5 by nipple and now d captures on c5
there's pressure here
so of course you have to react to this d
captures bishop captures with
check king to g2 now and the bishop back
to b6
uh we have rook a to b1 now preparing b4
and rook to c6 now now maybe you want to
double up on the c
file put pressure on this backwards c3
pawn we have b4
and now knight to c7 so what you do here
with b
captures uh or rather before capturing
here we have rook captures and e8
knight capture 78 and only now b
captures an a5 we have bishop captures
on a5
and now rook captures on b7 so this is
all uh very nicely done
uh and now you could um try and be
tricky with something like d4
saying that okay if c captures on b4
then i win the game
bishop captures knight captures and rook
to c2 attacks the knight you can't move
it there's a king on g2
that's it white resigns however after d4
you also have to consider
c4 it's a quite a sneaky idea and then
who know who knows what might happen uh
you don't really want to trade here
because then captures and all of a
sudden white has a two pass pawns you
don't really want to play against that
uh so instead after rook captures on b7
nothing so
fancy we have knight to d6 now first
pushing the rogue back we have rook to
a7 now attacking the
bishop also defending his past pawn and
bishop captures in c3 now
and now well you could capture here
first we have bishop to d7
now offering a trade this bishop that's
pretty much doing nothing for this
knight that could become very strong
so either you move the rook to something
like rook to c4 or you capture here
nipple decides to capture we have rook
captures uh but before rook captures we
have bishop captures on c3
getting rid of that one rook captures in
now rook characters and d7
uh we have rooked the c6 now preparing
uh not only uh
well not only is the knight defended but
also you are getting ready to play rook
to a6 the
to attack this pawn but first uh rook
the e7
so what do you play here uh well if you
go for something like rook to a6 right
away then
rook the e5 and then you this one is
under attack and if you traded the
this one for this pom pom then it's um
well it
we we can just call it a draw uh but
it's also move 39 we also
need to make one more move to reach time
control so here now nipple plays a bit
more complicated rook to c2 with
check and here we have king to g1
and with this move we've reached mu 40
and we are
granted additional time and now nepo
starts pushing his past pawn so d4
and uh now this is this is just
beautiful we have rook to d7
attacking the knight and now knight to
f5 and the
beautiful thing is that you can't kick
away the knights to win this pawn
because if you do this just knight h4
and now you can't win the pawn because
knight f3 check picks up the rook
so there's also that in the position so
this pawn is very much safe here
and uh how just starts pushing his own
past pawn so a5 and now
rook to a2 uh we have broke the a7
and as you know they say uh put a rook
behind the pass pawn not
in front of the pass pawn so it'd be of
course much better if the white rook was
here for for how
but it's not so it's a bit more
problematic we have king to f6
uh preparing the bringing the king into
the game and
a6 now we have h4 trying to bust open
uh black's king side and ruin his pawn
structure
and you don't really have a a good move
here because if you for
or rather okay for example if you
capture here just knight captures your
pawn structure is completely ruined
uh if you go g4 then knight to e3
extremely strong what you do here if you
trade then d
captures an e3 uh this is not covered if
if rook to a1 check comes you're gonna
have to move and then you know
the pawn just wins the game uh there's
no rook to e7 the king took care of that
so
after h4 not really good to capture or
or to push g4 so here we have rook the
a8
making room for this final push to a7
and
now comes uh h3 and this is a very
important move because it
takes away the g2 square from the white
king also the f2 square is taken by the
rook
so you have to be careful at some point
you know ideas like rook to g2
are coming so here we have a7 and now
king the e7 just taking care of uh all
of the squares and the back rank
here you could easily blunder the game
you always have to be careful when your
opponent pushes the pawn all the way
up to the board and there's a rook
behind it you don't want to play
something like king to e6 then just
rook delivers check you have to move the
king and then queen comes into the game
and you you can resign
but after i move like king to e7 of
course such things are not possible so
here we have g4
pushing the knight back and now knight
the d6
uh we have rooked the b8 uh giving up
the a7 pawn but
with a very nice idea here howa finds a
way uh on how to eliminate
this d4 pawn now we have rooked the b8
preparing a8 queen so you have to
capture the a7 pawn there's no
arguing that so rook captures and now
rook to b4
now you have to push the pawn because
this
the f5 square is taken the b5 square is
taken so you have to push it and now
rook to b3 and there's no defending the
pawn now so this pawn is lost
we have looked at a2 by nepo at least
grabbing some activity with the rook and
now rook
captures on d3 uh now comes the knight
to c4
and here already you can uh very easily
make a mistake because it's not easy to
make a move for white uh
what do you what do you play here for
example if you try something like f4
which makes sense you know you want to
grab a lot of space here
rook g2 check and then after king h1
rook f2 and now your knight ndf
four pawn are under attack and uh well
you've just given up a pawn
so here uh we have knight the g3 by how
uh very interesting is knight the e3 i i
had to check this because you know there
there was a lot of controversy about
this game
uh online so i had to check knights the
e3 does
seem to lead to to to a definite draw uh
but i don't know how easy it is to
decide this from uh you know human
perspective because i've checked
check the table bases and the table base
say that after all the trades are done
here for example 93
captures captures with check king f6
now you have to find this f4 move which
attacks the h3 pawn now we go into this
rook g2
checking h1 rook captures on g4 rook
captures on h3 and rook captures on f4
so
this is a table based draw but i don't
know if
uh you know it's how easy it is to
deduce that from from this position
where uh hal had to decide what to play
here
so instead of knight to e3 he went for
knight to g3 which is not a mistake
but it does allow neapo some some very
uh
very cool ideas like rook to g2 with
check
king the h1 and now just uh king to f8
so what do you play here again it's your
move
uh rook the c3 just attacking the knight
uh and then now comes knight to b2 there
is the uh
seemingly cooler rook to d2 and now if
you capture the the knight
then it's just rook d1 check knight f1
and the rook captures on f1 checkmate
because this is covered
but of course this is not forced after a
move like rook to d2
we're just going to play rook king to g1
and now we're gonna have to repeat rook
g2 checking each one and then play the
move nipple already played so
in case you were wondering why nipple
went for knight to b2 instead of this
cool move
so knight to b2 and now rook to c8 with
check
king to g7 and now comes rook to d8
uh instead of this you could try rook to
b8 but you really have to keep an eye on
d1 and d3 because if you try something
like this knight d1
and knight to f2 will be checked maybe
there's no defending this look at this
beautiful checkmate
uh the this is nicely covered so there's
no defending this
so you absolutely have to cover the d1
and d3 squares
and now uh nipple goes for rook to f2
and again what do you play here
uh it's again a very tough decision for
white if you go rook to b8 you have to
try something the f3 pawn is being
threatened so you might try this
then if captures of course we can grab
the knight but you run into the exact
same
idea rook to d2 and what do you play now
rook to d1
is the threat uh you're gonna get
checkmated
and after king g1 now we play king to g2
check and now of course if we go
king to h1 then the same checkmate
applies so we're gonna have to go to f1
and then you just lose the h2 pawn for
free and this is now uh
well we'll be winning for black no doubt
so instead after rook to f2 we have king
to g1 right away by how
and now comes rook captures on f3 and
it's not a problem this is only one pawn
uh we have knight the e4 and now comes
rook to e3
again putting pressure on this knight
knight back to g3
and here nipple played rook to a3 and it
was in this position on move 59 that
wang ha resigned the game as uh well
it's not like there's nothing more to be
done there are
things that uh can be uh maybe done here
but
uh uh both of them agreed that uh well
nippo said after the game that uh this
is lost for white and one car
said that he's well very sure that this
is lost for white but
if you try to make moves here for white
you're gonna see that there really are
no
no moves that you can play uh because
nothing just works uh the king will
never get into the game i mean this h2
pawn is just the weak the h3 pawn is
very hard to uh be reached by white and
the g4 pawn is weak
simply because the h3 pawn isn't there
to help defend it and
if you get the king into the game you
can very easily win the pawn
so one thing that could happen is let's
say rook to e8
you you make a move with white you have
to play something we go
for example you want to maybe try to
somehow trade off
the rooks then win this spawn or trade
of the knights then maybe get the rook
into the game and somehow eliminate
blacks h3 pawn
so we might see something like knight to
d3 and then if rook the e3
now of course uh pinning the knight we
just play rook a1 check and if knight to
f1 now blocking this
uh knight to f4 nicely defends our h3
pawn and if rook to f3
we have to play this because well if the
king comes to g5 is just
over so you have to force g5 and then
it's just i mean this is
so disgusting uh to play with the white
uh you you would
you don't want to be in this position
because you can't win i mean
chances are okay there of course exists
a chance that nipple will mess something
up and
allow some sort of a super theoretical
draw but wang hao doesn't think that
such a such a thing is possible
and that's why he resigned here after
rook to a3
or i haven't seen the interview so if
you guys have any
greater insight as to why he resigned
you know you're welcome to share in the
comments i will
pin it so everyone else can see but i i
i'm pretty sure that
that's why uh why he resigned and
there's nothing for him to gain he's not
winning this game uh he is not becoming
a challenger to magnus carlsen and here
he i i think he just
lost all uh will to play to play this
game because i mean
here you could suffer for for the next
four days and it doesn't really
make sense because you still have to
play two more games in the candidates
tournament
and better you know to be refreshed for
them even though i guess tomorrow is a
rest day
so could be anything but um i don't
think we are you know looking at some
sort of a controversy here or you know
uh conspiracy i think this is just uh uh
you know a well thought game that
uh you know he he couldn't uh he
couldn't hold and a resignation was in
order
uh so uh i will i will show more games
from this round but i will show them
tomorrow so for those of you
who still don't know how the other games
ended uh you know close your eyes and
you know close this video because i will
now show the standings
after round 12 so these are the
standings uh there you have it
after 12 rounds yanni she is still in
the lead even though anishigiri
played that beautiful game against
fabiano corona he defeated him
uh and we thought that he would at least
catch up to nipple but
with winning you know by winning this
game against wang khao
yani pon still uh hangs on to first
place with
eight points then we have anish giri
with seven and a half maksim with six
and a half fabi with six uh grishop with
five and a half one cow and dinglier
with five and kiro alexenko with four
and a half
and i don't know um uh i don't think
fabi fabi is no longer uh in it you know
to win it
uh i think maksim still has a chance uh
to catch up to nepo if nip of course
loses
both of his uh games but it's not it's
not going to be easy so i think three of
them still have a chance
uh we're going to see so it's going to
be either nipple geary or or mbl
uh but two more rounds to go anything
can happen so we're gonna we're gonna
enjoy that uh you know
when it happens uh so yeah that's the
game i hope you guys enjoyed it
and uh you know uh have uh you know uh
calmed yourself regarding whether this
is a conspiracy or not
uh i would like to thank lucas berglund
robert lanier
uh mohamed salah safa yaakov gonzalez
and daniel silverberg for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing with the coverage of the
candidates checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day